most people who pay close attention to
pop culture are aware of Donald Glover's
extreme range of talents
he's the emmy-winning creator writer
star and occasional director of the FX
series Atlanta the grammy-winning rapper
childish gambino and even the young
version of Lando Calrissian
but before Glover was all of those
things and more he was shining bright as
the lovable jock Troy Barnes on the
beloved sitcom community
you'd be surprised of how many of your
favorite football players got started at
Community College really named one who's
your favorite player names whoa
running for six seasons between 2009 and
2015
community focused on the bizarre and
whimsical exploits of a group of seven
students attending a community college
it was never a huge hit in the ratings
but it had a devoted fan base and helped
kickstart the careers of its cast
members sadly during the hiatus in 2013
between community's fourth and fifth
seasons it was announced that Glover
would be leaving the show at some point
during the upcoming season NBC wound up
canceling community after season five
and though the now-defunct streaming
service Yahoo screen revived it for a
sixth season it never fully recovered
its early magic without Glover around
anymore so why did he leave in the first
place let's investigate in 2011 during
community's third season NBC put the
show on an indefinite hiatus while it
did return later that season it was an
ominous sign of what was to come in May
2012 after the third season ended Sony
television which produced the show fired
creator Dan Harmon then after a rocky
season for a regular cast member Chevy
Chase left the show as well in the wake
of his increasingly aggressive and
reportedly racist onset behavior
considering all this turmoil it's not
all that surprising that Glover decided
to take the star power he'd gained from
community and try something new on a
show that was decidedly calmer behind
the scenes in August 2013 it was
announced that Glover was creating the
half-hour comedy drama Atlanta for FX
though Harmon eventually returned for
community's fifth season and even
managed to persuade Glover to appear on
five episodes before truly calling it
quits he admitted that Glover had
outgrown the series a few months after
Glover announced his impending departure
from community he revealed that his
reasons for leaving were more than just
professional in nature in October 2013
he posted to Instagram a series of
letters explaining that he left
community because he wanted to be on his
own and was working through difficult
events in his personal life that made
him reassess what he truly wanted to do
he admitted to a ton of fears including
that he was worried that Dan Harmon
hated him that he was scared of letting
everyone down by moving on from
community and that he believed his
future projects might fail that kind of
stress adds up
[Applause]
nevertheless he said that he wanted to
release his album because the internet
that Christmas to give people hope for
the next year shortly thereafter Glover
clarified his jumbled thoughts in an
interview with vibe noting that his
heart really wasn't in it anymore
that wall community was a great show it
wasn't his show I just want to make dope
dope from now on like home on my own
time in 2016 Glover was more direct
about his decision to depart from
community two years after his last
episode aired and a year after the show
wrapped for good he revealed that he
chose to leave partially because he
appreciates the future opportunities
that endings create at the Television
Critics Association summer to her Glover
explained that while he wasn't trying to
run away from community he feels that
every good thing must come to an end in
order for growth to happen this of
course includes his run on the sitcom as
he explains I just like endings I think
everything should have death clauses in
them like humans have death clauses it's
important that things end it forces
events to progress since leaving
community Glover has received seven Emmy
nominations including two wins and seven
Grammy nominations including five wins
as for Glover's fears about his
community colleagues resenting him for
leaving them behind
they appear to have nothing but love and
admiration for him Troy's sailing
endeavor may not have gone well but
Glover's horizon is burning bright
no throw I know it's gonna be difficult
for you to interact with me that was the
original choice
I miss clone let's get the light upper
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]